Diggs took home the award for Best
Featured actor in a musical Bravo for
playing dual roles in the Broadway hit
the actor now stars in blind spotting
it's a new film that he co-wrote and
produced Diggs plays Colin an Oakland
man who was trying to stay out of
trouble during his final three days of
probation and oh boy in this clip his
best friend miles gives him a hard time
about his former girlfriend what is your
problem with Val Val is a disloyal when
you were in jail did she put money on
your books
did she come visit you even one time I
read a while you were locked up cuz I'm
pretty sure I went two times a week 45
minutes each way $500 on your book on
day warrant she talked to me on the
phone how gracious of her to have called
you once and what did she want to talk
to you about about changing up your
lifestyle changing up your ways you're
not a Doug drug dealer with the jail on
a fire technicality did I yes how are we
supposed to know that hipsters are so
flammable San Francisco Chronicle calls
a movie a serious work of passion
intuition and artistic intelligence the
B Diggs joins us now at the table good
morning to you good morning
and let's just say bravo to you in
Rafael Cassell in that scene Rafael and
you have been friends since high school
yeah he plays Miles and the two of you
wrote this you wrote this together for
over 10 years and writing it over sing
about a decade yeah yeah
just you know really with the impetus of
trying to show off Oakland California on
screen it's a we felt we had never seen
the city represented in the way that
that we know it to be so we were trying
to tell an Oakland story and and when
you do that you you come up against a
lot of other she was Oakland is like a
lot of other cities in the country but
it starts with a police shooting we
should say that discharge with the
police shooting it does when we started
conceiving the project was around 2009
right when Oscar Grant was was murdered
at Fruitvale BART station in Oakland so
the discussion in Oakland at the time
was around these was around police
shootings and Oscars face was on
everybody's t-shirt and and the the sort
of trauma of that incident
flash forward now I think the the
fantasy of all the protests around that
time was that things would change but
ten years later the biggest update we
made in the script is that
almost no one is affected by the tragedy
except Colin because he happens to be
there to witness it yeah I want to get
back to Oakland because Oakland is
changing that's what's about in the
movie but also there's this device you
use about probation mm-hmm and there's a
way in which is a viewer I may have this
totally wrong but you feel as a viewer
you're like oh my gosh is something
gonna go wrong before you feel the
tension which you must were you trying
to replicate the tension of what it's
like to be a young black man walking on
the streets with the cops always looking
after you
there's absolutely there's a there's a
there's a moment in the film where I
think almost everybody in the theater
sits in Colin's shoes in one of those
experiences and that's a really
gratifying experience because it's it's
it's a difference it's a cultural
difference that not everybody gets to
feel but when we're all in the theater
together we get to feel it I think and
probation is a is a that clock is a as a
technique right it's a filmic technique
to give it countdown but it's also real
if you know anybody on probation have
you've ever been on probation that's a
trap they're a series of traps set up to
send you back to jail because they make
money off of you in jail the issue of
race - between you and Myles is
interesting because you are really good
friends but there's also a lot of
friction in your relationship yeah well
you know Myles and Colin grew up
together they have almost exactly the
same context one happens to be why it
one happens to be black the changing
surroundings around them means that
their their context is changing and now
they are in different kinds of danger
because of how the outside world sees
them really having nothing to do with
anything they've built themselves but
that's a thing they have to reckon with
in in a changing society what's so
amazing about the the Probation idea is
that if you put a foot wrong you're
going back to jail but when that stops
when you're off probation the characters
are probation it's still there you know
you know that's what yeah yeah and there
yes there are traps everywhere for a lot
of different kinds of people and and you
know one of the biggest traps in the
film is poverty none of these people are
wealthy people none of them necessarily
have to meet the means to move or leave
their situation but the city is being
ripped out from under them so where are
they going to go you know as the rents
keep rising as as their fewer and fewer
things to do in the city that they can
participate in right and the reviews
have been phenomenal the New York Times
says blind spotting ought to be seen by
the widest audience possible many times
we have filmmakers here and say who do
you want this movie to be directed
towards oh yes to read the widest
audience possible that must be so
gratifying it is it is you know it's our
it's our first film and I think we get a
lot of credit for breaking convention
but I think a lot of that is because we
didn't know any of the conventions and
so that you were breaking yeah yeah but
it's now it's it's a dream come true
that it's actually coming out and and I
want more than anything for as many
people as possible and the title blind
spotting I think is genius and the way
you explain that in the movie yeah it's
a it's a it's a slang term we pride
ourselves on creating slang in the Bay
Area it's one it's one it's a very
Oakland thing to do and and all slang is
derivative so thou ow'st plays Colin's
girlfriend who miles is railing about in
that scene is studying psychology and
she creates slang terms as a way of
memorizing psych terms blinds fighting
is what she she comes up with to
remember this phenomenon of Rubin's vase
which you've probably seen that texture
yeah but it's either a vase or two faces
depending on when he's on how you see it
and all of your life experiences are
going to lead you to see one or the
other first it's not that you can't see
the other side is that you always have
to work for it your instinct always the
face is first yeah after that sailboat
scene there is a festival of slang which
is so delightful and that's all real
Oakland tonight we just had our premiere
in the town and and that scene you know
everybody follows that seemed better if
you're from okay that's a lot to be
proud of and basketball team and you can
be Thanks thank you thank you so much
for having me
line spotting opens in select cities on
Friday and expands nationwide on July
27th and you can hear more of CBS this
morning on our podcast available on
Apple's podcast app or wherever you like
to download your podcasts